shakira possibly facing time behind bars
here's what we know
[Music]
the don't wait up singer is battling
allegations of tax fraud in spain the
country claims she owes 14.5 million
euros which converts to about 15 million
dollars and now the case heads to trial
after shakira turned down a plea deal
offered by spanish prosecutors
her reps say shakira trusts her
innocence and chooses to leave the issue
in the hands of the law
[Music]
so how did these legal issues come about
for the she-wolf shantus
well the ap reports that a spanish judge
found sufficient evidence of criminality
during a three-year investigation of the
colombian superstar who has a home in
barcelona and recommended that her case
go to trial in december 2019 shakira was
charged for not paying her taxes between
2012 and 2014 while she lived in spain
however she testified in january 2019
and denied any wrongdoing
if shakira is found guilty of tax
evasion she faces a possible fine and an
eight-year prison sentence et is out to
her team for comment
despite shakira's legal troubles she's
staying focused on her career the grammy
winner is a judge on nbc's competition
series dancing with myself alongside
nick jonas and liza koshy pick it up
then drop it
shakira gets up and pop it
i think it's a show for everybody
not not only for professionals uh
most of the contestants who participate
i aren't i mean virtuosos or
or um
specialists they just enjoy dancing and
they want to share
their passion for it and they won't
express themselves on top of that
shakira is dropping new bangers
like her recent collab with rau
alejandro te felicito
[Music]
and get this shakira's kids whom she
shares with ex gerard pk played a big
role behind the concept of the music
video i had no idea what i was gonna do
and i asked him to listen to the song
close their eyes
and my little one came up with the idea
of the robot and my eldest one came up
with the idea of the green fire i'm like
that's it
i got it i got a video
and then from there i took all those
ideas those ideas and i and i've
developed it and
i i pretty much uh wrote the rest of the
of the script and
the synopsis of the of the video but
yeah it's i mean it's incredible what
kids can do right their imagination is
limitless and and they're so pure and so
uncorrupted and they're always ready to
create if we allow them big question is
now will the singer's kiddos be
following in their mama's footsteps i do
think that my kids are
they do have some kind of musical talent
and i don't know if they're going to be
professionals in this business
professionally professional musicians i
don't care i just i just want them to
have music in their lives because i
think it's it's going to be a
companionship down the road
[Music]
you